Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: John Ockey
Il perdono,
un sentimento celebrato da millenni
da filosofi, teologi e leader religiosi.
Spesso descritto
come un atto nobile, umanitario,
capace di elevare moralmente
lo spirito dell'uomo.
Eppure, così difficile da sentire,
specialmente quando il responsabile
si è reso colpevole di atti gravi,
che non possono, e non devono,
essere giustificati o dimenticati.
Nei prossimi minuti, vorrei parlarvi
delle origini di questo sentimento,
e rivelarvi in che modo, credo,
possa e debba essere sviluppato,
anche quando la gravità della situazione
può renderlo difficile e controverso.
Perché penso che il perdono
debba essere sviluppato?
Sicuramente,
abbiamo tutti vissuto l'esperienza
di essere trattati ingiustamente,
qualche volta.
Magari siamo stati abbandonati
da un caro amico, nel momento del bisogno,
oppure traditi da una persona
che amavamo molto.
Come ci siamo sentiti, in quel momento?
Probabilmente, la tristezza,
la rabbia e il risentimento
hanno iniziato a tormentarci,
e magari abbiamo anche iniziato
a desiderare di vendicarci
contro chi ci ha ferito.
Chi hanno danneggiato, però,
questi sentimenti?
Le persone che ci hanno fatto del male,
oppure soltanto noi stessi?
È su questa domanda
che vorrei riflettere con voi oggi,
perché sono convinta che,
come disse una volta
il grande scrittore americano Mark Twain,
"La rabbia è un acido
che può provocare più danno
al contenitore che la custodisce
che a qualsiasi oggetto
sul quale venga versato".
Ma qual è l'origine della rabbia?
E se ci provoca tanto danno,
come possiamo superarla?
Ricerche condotte nel campo
della psicologia sociale
hanno dimostrato che rabbia e risentimento
scaturiscono, principalmente,
dal modo in cui spieghiamo
le azioni di chi ci ha ferito.
Secondo questi studi,
quando ci troviamo
nella posizione della vittima
tendiamo a dipingere erroneamente
chi ci ha fatto del male
come una persona fondamentalmente cattiva.
Per esempio,
l'amico che ci ha abbandonato
è descritto come un opportunista,
il genitore che ci ha fatto
un torto, come un egoista,
e il nostro marito e nostra moglie
che ci ha tradito come un infedele.
Al contrario, però,
quando siamo stati noi a tradire qualcuno,
o a ferire qualcuno in qualche modo,
in genere tendiamo
a dipingere le nostre azioni
come risultato di accadimenti esterni
e circostanze al di là
del nostro controllo.
Per esempio, ci giustifichiamo
dicendo che la nostra
è stata soltanto una reazione
al comportamento negativo dell'altro,
oppure che in quel momento
eravamo sotto stress,
o che stiamo attraversando
un periodo difficile.
La ricerca dimostra, quindi,
che le persone tendono ad attribuire,
erroneamente, il comportamento degli altri
a caratteristiche fisse
della loro personalità,
e il proprio comportamento
a circostanze esterne.
Gli esperti chiamano questa tendenza
"errore di attribuzione".
La mia idea è che,
se vogliamo lasciare andare
la rabbia e il risentimento
che ostacolano lo sviluppo del perdono,
dobbiamo correggere
l'errore di attribuzione.
Secondo questa idea, quindi,
l'errore di attribuzione
è uno dei principali ostacoli al perdono,
e la causa di molti conflitti
che ci tengono separati l'uno dall'altro,
sia a livello individuale
che a livello collettivo.
A livello individuale, queste tendenze
portano a una separazione concettuale
tra il sé e l'altro.
L'altro diviene il sito
delle nostre proiezioni negative,
viene rappresentato come qualcosa
di diverso dal sé,
come un entità separata
che non merita rispetto.
Ferendo i nostri sentimenti,
e sfidando i nostri valori,
l'altro perde la sua dignità
di essere umano.
E può essere, quindi,
trattato di conseguenza.
A livello collettivo,
queste tendenze psicologiche
portano da un lato
a guerre e scontri interminabili,
come il conflitto israelo palestinese,
la guerra civile in Siria e il terrorismo.
Dall'altro portano alla creazione
di sistemi di giustizia
eccessivamente punitivi,
che prevedono pene carcerarie
severe e prolungate
anche per crimini minori.
Eppure, come dimostrano
gli altissimi livelli di recidiva
registrati tra i condannati
in vari paesi del mondo,
queste misure punitive non sono in grado
né di trasformare
il comportamento dei trasgressori,
né di porre fine ai conflitti sociali
e creare un mondo più sicuro.
Allora forse dovremmo chiederci:
la punizione e il carcere
sono davvero gli unici sistemi
a nostra disposizione per fare giustizia?
O esiste forse una maniera alternativa?
In effetti, esiste una strada alternativa.
Una strada che sfida
le nostre idee prestabilite
su come gli individui, e la società,
dovrebbero rispondere
alla violenza e al conflitto.
Secondo questa idea,
se l'obiettivo è di portare
pace e armonia nella nostra società,
i trasgressori devono essere aiutati
a sviluppare l'empatia
verso le loro vittime,
e a capire il danno
che le loro azioni hanno provocato.
A loro volta,
le vittime devono essere aiutate
a sviluppare la compassione e il perdono
verso i trasgressori,
nonostante la difficoltà della situazione.
Ma perché le vittime dovrebbero aspirare
a perdonare chi gli ha fatto del male?
La ricerca psicologica ha dimostrato
che trasformare rabbia e risentimento
in compassione e perdono
contribuisce positivamente
al benessere psicologico
e alla salute fisica
delle vittime nel processo.
I sostenitori del modello tradizionale
di giustizia sostengono, però,
che perdonare chi ha commesso un crimine
è irrispettoso nei confronti
del dolore della vittima
e dei valori della società.
A mio avviso, però, queste critiche
si basano su un'idea della relazione
tra il trasgressore e l'atto criminale
che non riconosce la fondamentale
giustificazione morale del perdono.
Infatti, mentre il sistema tradizionale
tende a identificare
il peccato col peccatore,
per riuscire a perdonare
senza però giustificare
dobbiamo separare l'atto criminale,
che può essere condannato,
dalla persona responsabile di tale atto,
che può invece essere perdonata.
Condannando il crimine ma non la persona,
da un lato manteniamo intatto
il rispetto per il dolore della vittima
e i valori della società
e dall'altra aiutiamo il trasgressore
a non identificarsi con il suo errore,
e la vittima a perdonare
il suo malfattore.
È sostenendo la separazione concettuale
tra il crimine e la persona
che il ruolo del sistema giudiziario
può risultare determinante
per lo sviluppo del perdono.
Ma il nostro sistema giudiziario
è in grado di sostenere
questa separazione concettuale?
Nel modello retributivo tradizionale,
l'equilibrio della bilancia
della Giustizia
si ottiene infliggendo
una punizione al trasgressore
commisurata al danno sociale
provocato dal crimine.
Secondo alcuni critici,
focalizzandosi esclusivamente
sull'azione da compiere
nei confronti del trasgressore,
il modello tradizionale tende a ignorare
i bisogni delle vittime, nel processo.
Infatti, privando le vittime
di una voce nel procedimento,
il sistema penale tende a negare loro
la possibilità di esprimere
i propri sentimenti e le proprie paure.
E di superare, così,
il trauma provocato dall'evento.
Per risolvere questo problema,
questi critici propongono
un modello alternativo di giustizia,
basato sulla riparazione del danno
provocato dal crimine
alle vittime e alla società,
anziché sulla quantità di punizione
da imporre al trasgressore.
[GIUSTIZIA RIPARATIVA
DANNO - RIPARAZIONE]
Ci sono vari metodi
per implementare questo modello:
ma quello che sicuramente
ha avuto più successo
è la conferenza riparativa.
La conferenza riparativa cerca di riunire
le vittime, i trasgressori
e i loro familiari
per tovare insieme
una soluzione costruttiva
ai danni provocati dal crimine,
aiutati da un mediatore imparziale -
in genere, un agente di polizia.
Mentre il sistema tradizionale si basa
su una relazione antagonistica
tra lo Stato e i trasgressori,
le conferenze riparative cercano di creare
una relazione di cooperazione
tra tutte le parti coinvolte,
in una dinamica di carattere circolare.
La mia idea è che,
mentre l'approccio antagonistico
del sistema tradizionale
raramente stimola il condannato
a chiedere scusa,
e le vittime a perdonare,
la natura cooperativa e circolare
della conferenza riparativa
crea l'ambiente ideale
affinché avvenga questo scambio.
Questa idea si basa su una serie di studi,
condotti in Australia e Nuova Zelanda,
che hanno dimostrato le straordinarie
potenzialità trasformative
di questo modello.
Come abbiamo visto, per esempio,
per riuscire a perdonare
la vittima deve riuscire a separare
l'identità del criminale
dal suo comportamento.
Per esempio, identificando
le circostanze esterne
che possono aver contribuito
alle sue azioni.
Gli studi australiani, e neozelandesi,
dimostrano che la maggioranza
delle conferenze riparative
sono in grado di sostenere
questa separazione concettuale:
infatti, quasi il 70 percento
delle vittime intervistate
in Nuova Zelanda
descrivevano il trasgressore
con una persona fondamentalmente buona
che aveva però compiuto
un'azione sbagliata,
mentre le vittime
intervistate in Australia
raramente disapprovavano
il trasgressore come persona.
D'altro canto, come abbiamo visto,
per riuscire a chiedere scusa
i trasgressori devono riuscire
a sviluppare l'empatia
verso le loro vittime
e a capire il danno
che le loro azioni hanno provocato.
Gli studi australiani dimostrano
che le conferenze riparative
sono più efficaci
dei processi penali tradizionali
nel facilitare questo tipo
di trasformazione.
Infatti, mentre nei processi
penali tradizionali
soltanto il 19 percento delle vittime
riportava di aver ricevuto delle scuse,
nelle conferenze riparative
queste percentuali schizzano
al 72 percento.
Questo dato è molto significativo,
perché la ricerca ha dimostrato
che le vittime sono
molto più inclini a perdonare
quando ricevono delle scuse,
come possiamo anche immaginare.
Infine, per riuscire a perdonare,
le vittime devono riuscire
a lasciare andare la rabbia
e a sviluppare la compassione
verso i trasgressori.
E ancora una volta,
gli studi condotti in Australia
dimostrano l'efficacia
della giustizia riparativa
per sostenere questa
trasformazione emotiva.
Infatti, mentre prima
delle conferenze riparative
il 63 percento delle vittime
provava rabbia verso il trasgressore,
dopo le conferenze
queste percentuali si dimezzano,
calando drasticamente al 29 percento.
Viceversa, se prima
delle conferenze riparative
soltanto il 19 percento delle vittime
provava compassione verso il trasgressore,
dopo le conferenze
queste percentuali raddoppiano,
raggiungendo il 48 percento.
Come dimostrano questi studi, quindi,
se completata con successo,
una conferenza riparativa
può contribuire alla creazione
di una nuova relazione
tra la vittima e il criminale.
E, col tempo, portare
al perdono e alla riconciliazione.
Alcuni critici sostengono, però,
che la giustizia riparativa
è basata su idee
un po' ingenue e utopistiche.
Essi enfatizzano l'egoismo
che pervade molte relazioni sociali,
sostenendo che queste smentiscono
la fiducia nelle doti empatiche dell'uomo
su cui si basa questo modello.
La ricerca psicologica
e sperimentale dimostra, però,
che se trattiamo le persone in modo onesto
queste saranno a loro volta più inclini
a comportarsi in modo onesto.
Se le trattiamo
come se fossero affidabili,
queste saranno a loro volta
più affidabili.
E se diamo loro una responsabilità attiva
queste la assumeranno
in maniera costruttiva.
Fidarsi della capacità umana all'empatia
non è quindi ingenuità,
ma una scelta basata
su un accurata osservazione
dei dati a nostra disposizione.
La giustizia riparativa
non è neanche una proposta utopistica.
Anzi, questo modello è oggi sviluppato
in vari paesi anglosassoni,
come gli Stati Uniti e l'Inghilterra,
in paesi devastati dalla guerra civile,
come la Rwanda,
e in varie altre parti del mondo,
tra cui anche l'Italia.
Nonostante questi progressi, però,
siamo ancora a uno stato embrionale.
Il sistema giudiziario è oggi
più che mai pieno di problemi:
per esempio, come molti
probabilmente sanno,
negli ultimi anni abbiamo assistito
a una crescita esponenziale
nel numero di carcerati
e altissimi livelli di ricaduta
dopo il rilascio.
Etichettando i trasgressori
come criminali,
li abbiamo di fatto spinti
a identificarsi con le loro azioni,
impedendo ogni possibilità di cambiamento.
Al contrario, se riusciamo a separare
l'identità del criminale dalle sue azioni,
e a ripensare che cos'è la giustizia
e che cosa vogliamo ottenere
attraverso il suo utilizzo,
possiamo creare un modello alternativo
che miri non tanto
all'inflizione della pena,
quanto al benessere e alla maturazione
di tutte le parti coinvolte:
vittime, trasgressori e collettività.
Fino ad oggi, ci siamo sempre chiesti:
quanta punizione dovremmo infliggere
per questo crimine?
E se invece iniziassimo a chiederci:
che cosa possiamo fare,
per ristabilire l'armonia perduta?
Grazie.
(Applausi)